this is a free tutorial from our
inventory tutorial series you can find
it in the guru 3 course in the pro
version and in the standalone UI course
product so this will show you how to
create an inventory system with item
management that will then reuse in an
upcoming sharp tutorial and on top of
that you will see how to work on the
interface and create something that's
inspired by old-school Japanese RPGs but
more importantly it shows how to manage
complex UI in Godot like some of the
best practices you can use the inventory
system itself is a long series now lots
of interconnected videos so I took this
one a quick tip that I hope will help
you make better you eyes thank you for
your time enjoy the tutorial to give you
some context in this tutorial in Godot
you can use a grid container to arrange
control nodes so UI widgets in a grid
the grid node has a columns parameter
and as you add items it will
automatically place them in the
corresponding column so if we have two
columns we get two items per row but if
we have four columns we get four items
per row these item button scenes are set
to take the entire space of their parent
so if I open the item button the buttons
just have a minimum size to start with
and then if we only have two columns the
buttons will expand horizontally to take
the entire cell's width and on the grids
if we go down to the custom constants
like the V box and H Box containers it
has some separation values that creates
the gutter you can see between rows and
columns now the thing is if I'm to take
my item buttons and I make it so in the
size flags category they don't expand
horizontally I get aligned to the left
of the grid cell and the grid system is
going to use the size of the button to
set the size of a column if I have one
button
somewhere that uses the expand flag
horizontally also push the column to
take all the available horizontal space
respecting the size of the items in the
second column or in the third column so
if we were to have three columns here
it's this fifth button that is set to
expand so it takes all the available
space minus the width of the button on
the left column and the width of the
button on the right column making the
center column larger one last note
around this tutorial in the inventory
course I show you can use a disabled and
flat button that's invisible to make
sure that you always have at least one
item in your grid the problem is if you
hide all the items but one if one is set
to expand the grids
column the first one will take all the
available space except for the size of
the second column but as there is no
second item inside of the grid while the
second column has a size of zero pixels
so you need to use a dummy item that
will also expand horizontally to make
sure that it makes the second column as
large as the first one so a button takes
the entire space it can right now the
item button and the dummy button are
competing for space what if you want
your item to only take maybe a few
hundred pixels and not go beyond that
I'm gonna open the item button and
remove the expand flag this way it will
not resize to take all the space it can
in the items menu so heading back to the
items menu you can see now the item
button uses the minimum size I had
assigned to it if I remove it it
collapses it gets pushed around by the
dummy button if we add a minimum size to
the base seen in the rectangle category
let's say 300 pixels you do that and go
back to the items menu the item will
only take that amount of space and it's
aligned to the left of the grid cell
it's
inside of and if we dublicate in this
item now you're going to see the second
one takes a lot more space because these
items button are set with the layout
menu to anchor to the Forex of their
parent and our dummy button below is set
to expand and push the grid row to take
all the available space but as we have a
fixed size on our item button on the
other one it's going to make it so the
second column is only the size of that
item button if I hide the dummy button
and effectively you remove it from the
grid you're going to see items have a
fixed size like you'd expect as our grid
only has two columns if I go back to the
inspector to the top you can see it has
two columns and I dublicate the item it
will go to the next row as you'd expect
so now how do you Center an item inside
a row well you've got to use some
container so you've got to add an extra
control node or element that will fill
the entire row and have the item as a
child of it let's add this all testing
purposes we are going to add a simple
container maybe with a control node this
could work let's see so I'll add our
item button as a child of that control
mode make sure the item is first in the
grid we will Center it in size the
control node and make it so the control
node expands horizontally to take all
the available space and now our button
is centered inside the control node we
can call it expander or give the note a
name that works let's make sure it has a
minimum vertical size 60 pixels like the
item it contains and now when we
duplicate it it's going to take all the
available space in the current row it's
going to compete with the other expander
that the item button is not set to
expand horizontally so it will only have
its minimum size and as we set it to
stay centered inside its parent it's
going to stay Center
inside that expand a note so that's one
way you can Center buttons and rows this
is slightly less convenient that working
with the item buttons straight and the
reason for that is you have an extra
note you need to navigate down to get
access to the items buttons label amount
and icon which were going to change from
the code but for now I will go back to
the item button so I'm going to leave
the minimum size because it seems nice
that way and set it to expand
horizontally save go back to my items
menu and all items updates to take as
much space as they can